Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com burned on the water. The poop was beaten gold, purple the sails, and so perfumed that the winds were lovesick with them. The oars were silver, which to the tune of flutes kept stroke, and made the water which they beat to follow faster as amorous of their strokes. For her own person, it beggared all description. She did lie in her pavilion, cloth of gold of tissue, her picturing that Venus where we see the fancy outwork nature. On each side her stood pretty dimpled boys, like smiling cupids, with diverse fans whose winded seemed to glow the delicate
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需每周独家特辑、无广告收听、剧集抢先看以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com。水面燃火。船尾是精金打造，紫帆随风，香气袭人，连风都为之神魂颠倒。银桨伴随着长笛的旋律起落，催得被击起的水花欢快地跟在后面，仿佛爱慕着每一次划桨。至于她本人，更是无法用言语形容。她斜倚在织金锦缎的华盖下，那扮相宛如我们在画作中看到的维纳斯，以精妙的工艺超越了自然。她身侧站着几个面容姣好、带着酒窝的男孩，宛如微笑的丘比特，手中执着各式羽扇，扇出的微风仿佛能点燃那吹拂的娇嫩
cheeks which they did cool and what they undid did so dominic that's famous famous speech from shakespeare's antony and cleopatra yeah describing cleopatra's arrival at the port of tarsus in the south of what's now turkey to meet mark antony and at last you know fans of the romance of Tarsus in the south of what's now Turkey to meet Mark Antony. And at last, fans of the romance of Antony and Cleopatra, we have got to Antony. So in the previous two episodes, we described the context for Cleopatra. We described her relationship with Julius Caesar. And when we left her, she is pretty secure on her throne. She's bumped off anyone who might be a threat to her. But meanwhile, out in the broad world, Caesar's assassins are preparing to face down his Avengers. And there are essentially three significant players in the army of Caesar's
面颊……哦，那是莎士比亚《安东尼与克莉奥帕特拉》中著名的独白。是的，它描述了克莉奥帕特拉抵达现今土耳其南部塔尔索斯港，去会见马克·安东尼的情景。终于，各位《安东尼与克莉奥帕特拉》传奇故事的粉丝们，我们讲到安东尼了。在前两集里，我们讲述了克莉奥帕特拉的背景，讲述了她与尤利乌斯·凯撒的关系。当我们讲到她时，她的王位已经相当稳固。她除掉了所有可能对她构成威胁的人。但与此同时，在广阔的外界，凯撒的刺客们正准备迎战他的复仇者们。凯撒复仇者军团中基本上有三个重要人物。
Avengers. There's a bit of a cipher called Lepidus. Master of the horse. Master of the horse, not much. It doesn't do much else. Then there is Julius Caesar's adopted son, who takes the name Julius Caesar, but who is generally known as Octavian. And then there is Caesar's most significant kind of second in command, his right-hand man, the man who's consul when Caesar gets murdered, Mark Antony. Well, this is the point, Tom, where I should say the thing that I've been waiting to say. Yesterday, my son and I were casting the film of Cleopatra. So Gal Gadot, as we discussed in episode one, wants to make a Cleopatra film.
有一个叫雷必达的无名小卒。骑兵长官。骑兵长官，没多大本事。也没干别的什么。然后是尤利乌斯·凯撒的养子，他继承了尤利乌斯·凯撒的名字，但通常被称为屋大维。接着是凯撒手下最重要的二把手、他的得力助手，也就是凯撒遇刺时的执政官——马克·安东尼。好了，汤姆，这时候我该说出我一直想说的话了。昨天，我和我儿子在选角电影《克莉奥帕特拉》的角色。所以，盖尔·加朵正如我们在第一集里讨论过的，想拍一部克莉奥帕特拉的电影。
So Gal Gadot is Cleopatra. My view is that Oscar Isaac, who some people may know as Moon Knight from the Marvel series or Poe Dameron from Star Wars, should be Mark Antony. And do you know who would play Octavian? No. Well, you want someone young, but somebody who appears, as Octavian did,
所以盖尔·加朵演克莉奥帕特拉。我的看法是，奥斯卡·伊萨克——有些人可能知道他是漫威剧集《月光骑士》里的月光骑士，或是《星球大战》里的波·达默龙——应该演马克·安东尼。你知道谁来演屋大维吗？不知道。嗯，你需要一个年轻的演员，但要那种看起来像屋大维那样，
to be ordinary and to be kind of pleasant, but has an inner steel. Timothy Chalamet. No, it's Tom Holland. It's Spider-Man. Tom Holland. Yes, that's very good. Wouldn't he be good as Octavian?
显得很普通、很平易近人，但内心却坚如磐石的人。蒂莫西·柴勒梅德。不，是汤姆·赫兰德。是蜘蛛侠。汤姆·赫兰德。是的，这非常好。他不适合演屋大维吗？
Yes, he would. Oh, very good. But that would be terrible for you, of course, because when people Googled Tom Holland, Rome, or something. But he'd be quite good for the sales of Rubicon. He would. Oh, very good. But that would be terrible for you, of course, because when people Googled Tom Horne, Rome or something. But it'd be quite good for the sales of Rubicon. It would. Which I should just mention. So we've been selling your book on Cleopatra for children is out.
是的，他很适合。哦，非常棒。但这对你来说当然糟透了，因为当人们在谷歌上搜索汤姆·赫兰德、罗马之类的内容时……但这对比路康的销量挺有帮助的。是的。哦，非常棒。但这对你来说当然糟透了，因为当人们在谷歌上搜索汤姆·霍恩、罗马之类的内容时。但这对比路康的销量挺有帮助的。确实如此。顺便提一下。所以我们一直在卖你写的儿童版克莉奥帕特拉的书。
Do you mind if I just mention my book, Rubicon, which is about this very period? The audience would love it. And what's more, I should do it for you. Because if you want a sort of a deep dive into the intrigues, the Roman intrigues behind all this, the death of the Roman Republic, the great drama of the death of Julius Caesar, the fall of Pompey, the checker career of Mark Antony and the rise of Octavian, Tom's book Rubicon is absolutely the book for you. I mean, that's the book that really
你介意我顺便宣传一下我的书《卢比孔河》吗？这本书正是讲这段时期的。听众一定会喜欢它。而且更重要的是，我应该为你做这件事。因为如果你想深入了解这一切背后的阴谋、罗马的阴谋、罗马共和国的灭亡、尤利乌斯·凯撒遇刺的宏大戏剧、庞培的垮台、马克·安东尼跌宕起伏的生涯以及屋大维的崛起，汤姆的书《卢比孔河》绝对是你的不二之选。我的意思是，那本书真的是
made you, isn't it? That's the book that established your historical career. It is. So it's very close to my heart. It's very sweet of you to big it up like that. It doesn't have an endorsement from Ian McEwan or somebody like that. Yeah, it was his book of the year. It was in The Guardian. I remember reading it.
让你一举成名的书，对吧？那是确立你历史学家生涯的书。确实是的。所以它对我意义非凡。你这样大力夸赞它，真是太贴心了。它没有伊恩·麦克尤恩或者其他什么人的背书吗？对，那是他的年度之书。它登上了《卫报》。我还记得读过它。
Top punch in the air. They're like novelists recommending it. Exactly. We all are birds of a feather. So anyway, yes. list to recommend exactly we all are birds of a feather um so anyway yes so so there's this cleopatra is sort of off stage in this at this period isn't she's gone back to alexander well she's being leaned on by the assassin so that's brutus and cassius to send a fleet and there's an opportune storm that prevents the yeah prevents the fleet from going so basically cleopatra you
太棒了，扬眉吐气。就像有小说家推荐一样。没错。我们都是一路人。所以总之，是的。列出推荐，没错，我们都是一路人。嗯，所以总之，是的，所以——克莉奥帕特拉在这个时期似乎退居幕后了，不是吗？她回到了亚历山大。好吧，她正受到刺客——也就是布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯——的施压，要求她派遣一支舰队，而一场及时的大雨阻止了……是的，阻止了舰队的出征。所以基本上，克莉奥帕特拉
know sits it out she's she's being neutral which is, just to go back to the geopolitics, to remind people of this into the first two episodes, this is such a difficult situation for her because she knows that the Romans have been eyeing up Egypt for so long. She knows that if she makes one wrong choice, and that's the end of her, her dynasty, and Egypt's independence probably. So sitting it out is probably better than jumping into the civil war, but still risky.
你知道的，她选择了作壁上观，她保持中立。回到地中海地缘政治，为了提醒大家注意前两集的内容，这对她来说是一个多么艰难的局面啊。因为她知道罗马人对埃及虎视眈眈已经很久了。她知道，只要自己做出一个错误的选择，她的一切、她的王朝以及埃及的独立很可能就此终结。因此，作壁上观可能比直接卷入内战要好，但依然充满风险。
Yeah, still risky. And so she's watching as, you know, it's a bit of an action replay, isn't it? Caesar and Pompey are farceless. So there's another showdown in Greece, this time at Philippi, in which Antony, really, rather than Octavian, am I right in saying? Wins the day against Brutus. Octavian's sick in his tent. Yeah.
是的，依然充满风险。所以她在观望，你知道的，这有点像一场动作重播，不是吗？凯撒和庞培的较量。因此希腊又迎来了一场决战，这次是在菲利普比。在这次战役中，与其说是屋大维，倒不如说是安东尼——我没说错吧？——战胜了布鲁图斯。当时屋大维正躺在帐篷里生病呢。是的。
Tom Holland is sick in his tent. Which is later used by Anthony to beat Octavian, isn't he? He says, you're just a weed and you sat it out pretending to be ill. So she gets the news of all this. And then Octavian and Anthony do this division. And Lepidus. I mean, Lepidus gets North Africa. But let's park Lep do this division and lepidus i mean the sofia lepidus gets north africa but let's let's park lepidus so lepidus gets phased out we'll just forget about him we'll forget about him so essentially the world gets divided in two
汤姆·赫兰德正躺在他的帐篷里生病。安东尼后来用这个来打击屋大维，不是吗？他说，你不过是个懦夫，装病躲在一旁作壁上观。于是她收到了这一切的消息。然后屋大维和安东尼进行了权力划分。还有雷必达。我是说，雷必达得到了北非。但我们先搁置雷——进行这种划分，还有雷必达，我是说，索菲亚——雷必达得到了北非，但我们——让我们把雷必达搁置一边，所以雷必达被逐渐边缘化了，我们就不管他了，我们不管他了。所以基本上，世界被一分为二了。
yeah and anthony at this point tom i'm right in thinking am i that anthony appears to be very much the senior partner the east is richer more cosmopolitan, more cities. Well, also, Italy is a massive poison chalice because there are vast numbers of legions on both sides and they have to be settled. They have to be found land. So that is going to require whoever goes back to Italy to requisition land, which will make him incredibly unpopular. So that's why Antony thinks, I will go off to the East. I will, you know, screw gold out of all these kings and queens. And then I'll have a crack at the Parthians, the old enemy. Win glory that way. And the screwing the gold, that's why he sends this bloke, Quintus Delius, to Alexandria and says, I want Cleopatra to come to Tarsus.
是的。而且安东尼在这个时候，汤姆，我没记错吧，安东尼似乎明显是高级合伙人。东方更富裕、更具大都会气息，城市也更多。嗯，同时，意大利也是一个巨大的毒酒杯，因为双方都有大量的军团，必须妥善安置他们。必须为他们找到土地。因此，任何回到意大利去征用土地的人都会变得极其不受欢迎。这就是为什么安东尼认为，我要去东方。我要去，你知道的，从所有这些国王和女王那里搜刮黄金。然后我去挑战帕提亚人，那个老敌人。以此赢得荣耀。而搜刮黄金，这就是为什么他派了这个叫昆图斯·德利乌斯的家伙去亚历山大，并说，我要让克莉奥帕特拉去塔尔索斯。
Because he's basically wants to screw gold out of her. Yeah. Isn't he? Yeah. He wants to exploit her. Because that passage you read at the beginning from Shakespeare, that is Shakespeare's, I mean, frankly, almost word for word rendition of Plutarch describing. I mean, we already had Cleopatra in the last episode in her famous carpet incarnation or sort of bed sack incarnation rolling out to Greek Julius Caesar. So now she makes this tremendous entrance at Tarsus.
因为他基本上想从她那里搜刮黄金。是的。不是吗？是的。他想剥削她。因为你刚才在开头读的那段莎士比亚的文字，那是莎士比亚的——坦白说，几乎是逐字逐句地引用了普鲁塔克的描述。我的意思是，我们在上一集里已经见识过克莉奥帕特拉了，她以著名的地毯化身或某种床垫化身出场，滚到希腊人尤利乌斯·凯撒面前。现在，她又以这般宏大的气势在塔尔索斯登场了。
Yes. She's dressed as, I mean, there are different, do you think she was dressed as Isis? Well, some people say dressed as Aphrodite, but she's certainly dressed as a goddess, isn't she? She's both because there's no sharp division. She's multiple things. The context for this is that Antony is laying down the law and there's a lot of big dick energy here. He is the guy on the scene. He is making sure that everybody knows that he is the top guy. He's summoning Cleopatra to make it clear to Cleopatra that she has to do what he says. And so for Cleopatra as queen, it's a humiliation that she is having to answer the summons. It's about making clear to Antony and
是的。她打扮成……我的意思是，有不同的说法，你觉得她打扮成伊西斯了吗？嗯，有人说打扮成阿弗洛狄忒，但她显然打扮成了一位女神，不是吗？她两者兼具，因为这并没有明确的界限。她是多重身份的化身。这一切的背景是，安东尼正在树立威严，这里充满了雄性荷尔蒙的气息。他是现场的主导者。他要确保每个人都知道他是老大。他传召克莉奥帕特拉，是为了向她表明她必须听从他的指挥。因此，对于身为女王的克莉奥帕特拉来说，不得不应召前去是一种羞辱。这关乎向安东尼和
to everybody that she is a queen and perhaps a goddess. And so therefore, she's not someone to be bossed around like that. But at the same time, Plutarch says this. She is doing what she did with Caesar, which is trying to appeal to her understanding of this guy's character. So she's met Antony. She knows Antony. It's not like they've never met before. She's very, very familiar with Antony. What's Antony like?
所有人明确表明，她是一位女王，或许还是一位女神。因此，她不是那种可以任人呼来喝去的人。但与此同时，普鲁塔克这样写道。她正在做她对凯撒做过的事，也就是试图迎合她对这个男人性格的理解。所以她见过安东尼。她了解安东尼。这并不是说他们以前从未见过面。她对安东尼非常非常熟悉。安东尼是个什么样的人？
Because Antony is not your standard, serious, sober Roman general, is he? He's a very shrewd political player. He is hard-nosed brutal he's very charismatic he likes a drink uh he identifies with dionysus yes he loves dressing up he loves dressing up so there's all these kind of stories about how he dresses up as dionysus and frolics around the acropolis in athens i mean he really is the Justin Trudeau of Roman generals. Kind of. He's a very efficient general. This is why he's come to power with Caesar.
因为安东尼可不是那种标准、严肃、稳重的罗马将军，对吧？他是一个非常精明的政治玩家。他意志坚定、冷酷无情。他极具个人魅力。他喜欢喝一杯。嗯，他把自己等同于狄奥尼索斯。是的。他喜欢盛装打扮。他喜欢盛装打扮。所以有各种各样的故事说他打扮成狄奥尼索斯，在雅典的卫城周围寻欢作乐。我的意思是，他简直就是罗马将军里的贾斯汀·特鲁多。差不多吧。他是一位非常能干的将军。这就是他随凯撒一起崛起的。
But compared to Caesar, he is coarse. He's not as an intellectual in the way that Caesar was. And there's a deep strain of vulgarity. And if you listen to that account, the Shakespeare mediating Plutarch, it has the kind of beauty of great poetry. But if you boil it down and think, well, what would that actually look like? It would be a bit vulgar. It's all bling, isn't it? It's all bling.
但与凯撒相比，他显得有些粗俗。他不像凯撒那样是个知识分子。并且他身上有着很深的庸俗色彩。如果你听刚才那段由莎士比亚转述普鲁塔克的描述，它具有伟大诗歌般的美感。但如果你把它剥丝抽茧，想象一下那在现实中究竟是什么样子，其实会觉得有点俗气。全都是珠光宝气，不是吗？全都是珠光宝气。
Because then she throws a series of parties for him. And if you read the Plutarch and the other accounts, it's kind of golden couches golden crockery tapestries yeah the lighting is arranged so everything looks purple and gold so it looks like a kind of russian oligarchs boudoir and at the end of the evening she's always saying to him well you say the gold plates have some more you know gold tablecloths or whatever but anthony loves all this he doesn't see through it he just thinks oh this is brilliant loads of bling i think he absolutely sees through it and i think that if anyone is exploiting anyone at this stage it's antony is exploiting cleopatra but that does change quite quickly it does but but at this stage antony is if he wants the money he needs to pay off his legions yeah if cleopatra wants to shut
因为随后她为他举办了一系列宴会。如果你读普鲁塔克和其他人的记载，那简直是金色的长椅、金色的餐具、挂毯。是的，灯光经过精心布置，一切都呈现出紫色和金色，看起来就像某个俄罗斯寡头的闺房。而且每天晚上宴会结束时，她总是对他说：“哎呀，你说金盘子，那就再来点吧，你知道的，金桌布什么的。”但安东尼很喜欢这一切。他没有看穿这些，他只是觉得：“哦，这太棒了，有这么多的珠光宝气。”我觉得他绝对看穿了。而且我认为，如果说在这个阶段有人在剥削谁的话，那是安东尼在剥削克莉奥帕特拉。但这种情况很快就发生了变化。确实如此。不过在这个阶段，安东尼如果想要钱，他就需要支付军团的薪水。如果克莉奥帕特拉想砸给他镀金的东西，那太棒了，你知道的，他还可以顺便和她睡觉。她也得到了等价的回报，那就是他同意除掉她的妹妹——也就是你在上一集里形容为“累赘”的阿尔西诺伊。这是一种等价交换，就像当年凯撒和克莉奥帕特拉之间那样。但克莉奥帕特拉在安东尼面前展示的诱饵，也是她当年在凯撒面前展示的诱饵，那就是建立某种王朝联合的前景。也就是一种融合了罗马、希腊化、共和制与君主制的混合体。而克莉奥帕特拉构建这一切的方式是——莎士比亚的作品中曾暗示过这一点，你也暗示过——通过将自己塑造成一位女神，将自己塑造成伊西斯，将自己塑造成阿弗洛狄忒，并暗示着她所扮演的
chuck gold-plated him brilliant you know and he can sleep with her at the same time she gets a quid pro quo which is that he agrees to wipe out her sister, who you described as a baggage in the previous episode, Arsinoe. It's quid pro quo, as it was with Caesar and Cleopatra as well. But what Cleopatra also dangles in front of Antony is what she dangled in front of Caesar, which is the prospect of a kind of dynastic union. So a kind of mutant Roman Hellenistic, Republican monarchical kind of fusion. And the way in which Cleopatra frames this is by, you know, it's alluded to in the Shakespeare, you alluded to it, by casting herself as a goddess, by casting herself as Isis, by casting herself as Aphrodite, by hinting at the role that she
众神之女王的角色。因为当然，如果安东尼与众神之女王同床共枕，那么这就会抬高他的身份，将他塑造为赫拉克勒斯、狄奥尼索斯或者其他任何他想扮演的神祇——无论是哪个神，奥西里斯。所以安东尼在顺着这个思路，你知道的，他开始对此动心了。嗯，他很喜欢这个，不是吗？但事实是，他并没有对她神魂颠倒。你知道的，在莎士比亚的戏剧中，开场就是这样的，这就是故事开场的时期。他正和她厮混在一起。克莉奥帕特拉有句著名的台词：“哦，突然之间，罗马的思绪击中了心房。”你知道的，安东尼需要回去，重新承担起他的责任。事实并非如此。
plays as the Queen of the Heavens. Because of course, if Antony sleeps with the Queen of the Heavens, then that dignifies him and casts him as Heracles or Dionysus or whoever, whichever god, Osiris, whichever god he wants to play. And so Antony plays with, you know, he's starting to toy with that. Well, he loves this, doesn't he? But the truth is that he is not head over heels with her. You know, in Shakespeare's play, it opens with, this is the period where it opens. He is kind of hanging out with her. Cleopatra has this kind of the famous line, oh, on the sudden the Roman thought hath struck him. You know, Antony needs to go back and kind of resume his responsibilities. That's not what happened.
安东尼此时对自己的职责掌控得游刃有余。他在亚历山大搜刮钱财。我正要说的是，这发生在公元前41年夏末土耳其南部的塔尔索斯，也就是现在的土耳其南部。在公元前41年底，安东尼前往亚历山大。有趣的是，他不像尤利乌斯·凯撒那样，周围簇拥着士兵和诸如此类的前呼后拥。他没有大张旗鼓，而是去度了一个冬假。一次城市度假。是的，一次城市度假。
Antony is absolutely on top of his brief at this point. He's in Alexandria screwing money out. What I was about to say, so this was in Tarsus in southern Turkey, what's now southern Turkey, in the late summer of 41. At the end of 41, Anthony goes to Alexandria. Interestingly, he doesn't go as Julius Caesar did, surrounded by soldiers and all that sort of thing. He goes with no pomp for a kind of winter holiday. A city break. Yeah, a city break.
他穿着普通公民的衣服。他出行时没有仪仗队簇拥。也就是从那时起，开始流传关于两人举办宴会、过着神仙般生活的最初故事，比如他们盛装打扮、上街狂欢之类的传闻。好了，汤姆，你不觉得就在那个时候，原本这种因便利而产生的浪漫关系——浪漫这个词我用得有点勉强——这种因便利而产生的关系。他在冬季月份去那里进行城市度假，这其中显然产生了一些超越单纯政治利益的火花。毫无疑问，那里确实有火花。但我毫不怀疑，安东尼占据着主导地位。这其中的一个证据是，克莉奥帕特拉重新夺回了塞浦路斯。是的。塞浦路斯曾经被剥夺。安东尼把它收回了。他并没有把东西施舍给她。他在从她手里夺取。一切都是索取、索取、索取。如果他能从她身上榨取到情欲、神圣地位和王朝野心，那当然很好。这很说明问题。我觉得你刚才说这话时带着太多的津津乐道。这很说明问题，正如克莉奥帕特拉怀上凯撒的孩子一样，她也怀上了
And he dresses as an ordinary citizen. He doesn't go surrounded by pageantry and stuff. And that's when you get the first stories about the two of them having banquets and living the sort of life of Riley, stories about them dressing up and going out on the town and all this kind of thing. Now, at that point, Tom, don't you think at that point, what was initially a romance of convenience and romance is using, I'm stretching the term, a relationship of convenience. The fact that he is there on the city break over the winter months, that there is clearly some kind of spark there that goes beyond the nakedly
安东尼的孩子。而且不愧是克莉奥帕特拉，你知道的，她做事从不半途而废，她为他生了一对龙凤胎——亚历山大·赫利俄斯，也就是亚历山大太阳神，还有克莉奥帕特拉·塞勒涅，也就是月亮。当然，“亚历山大”这个名字，就是我们在播客一开始谈论过的，作为我们的亚历山大播客的续集，每个人都觉得自己正在经历《亚历山大大帝传》的续集。显然这就是那个名字。克莉奥帕特拉的帝国野心就直接体现在这个名字里，不是吗？确实如此。对于安东尼来说，这等同于一只狗在路灯柱上撒尿。
political. Unquestionably, there's a spark there. But I think unquestionably, Antony is making the running. So one piece of evidence for that is that Cleopatra has reappropriated Cyprus. Yes. Had been taken from her. Antony takes it back. He's not handing out things to her. He's taking from her. It's all take, take, take. And if he can take from her, you know, erotic pleasure and divine status and dynastic pretensions, then that's great. And it's telling. I think you said that with too much relish. It's telling that just as Cleopatra gets pregnant with caesar she also gets pregnant
他在划定自己的地盘。因为在搞定这一切、让她怀孕之后，他就离开了，而且四年没再见她。嗯，这不是很迷人的一点吗？所以，在你那些标准的、被美化和极度浪漫化的故事版本里，这部分内容恰恰缺失了。他随后离开了，回到了雅典，他的妻子福尔维娅就在那里。福尔维娅去世了。福尔维娅是个可怕的女人。我们在上一集里提到了西塞罗。西塞罗和安东尼互不顺眼。西塞罗曾对安东尼出言不逊、尖酸刻薄。西塞罗还与福尔维娅的第一任丈夫克洛狄乌斯有过长期宿怨。
with anthony and being cleopatra you know she never does anything by half she gives him twins alexander helios alexander the sun yeah and cleopatra selene the moon yeah but obviously the name alexander that's the name we talked about these podcasts right at the beginning as the sequel to our alexander the podcast, and everybody thinks they are living through the sequel to the life of Alexander the Great. And obviously that is a name. Cleopatra's imperial ambitions are right there in that name, aren't they? They are. For Antony, it's equivalent of a kind of dog weeing on the lamppost.
所以福尔维娅非常痛恨西塞罗。当西塞罗在三巨头（安东尼、雷必达和屋大维）的命令下被斩首时，他的断头被送到了福尔维娅面前。她拔下头上的发簪，狠狠地扎向那根曾在演说中攻击安东尼的舌头。当屋大维回来试图为军团解决所有的土地问题时，福尔维娅甚至发动了针对他的战争。我的意思是，她是一个非常、非常令人生畏的女人。很显然，安东尼喜欢非常坚强、有权势的女人。用你的术语来说，汤姆，她确实是个累赘。
He's marking out his territory because having done it, having got her pregnant, he then leaves and he doesn't see her for four years. Well, that's the fascinating thing, isn't it? So that's what's sort of missing in your standard sort of glamorised, ultra-romantic versions of the story, that he then, he goes off, he goes back to Athens where his wife Fulvia is. Fulvia dies. Fulvia is a terrifying woman. So we mentioned Cicero in the previous episode. Cicero and Antony hated each other. Cicero had been sensationally rude about Antony. Cicero had also had a running feud with Fulvia's first husband, Clodius.
她确实是个累赘。嗯，是的，她是一个非常、非常坚强、极具影响力且令人敬畏的女人。但她突然暴毙了，不是吗？是的，确实如此。而安东尼对此的反应并不是“太好了，我可以娶克莉奥帕特拉了”。实际上，他是与他的三巨头同僚、合作伙伴兼竞争对手屋大维缔结了婚姻同盟。他娶了屋大维娅。他确实这么做了。所以他们在——他娶了屋大维娅。他确实这么做了。
So Fulvia really hated Cicero. And when Cicero gets beheaded on the orders of the Triumvirs, the Antony, Lepidus and Octavian, his severed head is taken to Fulvia and she takes out her hairpins and stabs the tongue that uttered the orations against Antony up against Octavian when he comes back to try and sort out all the land for the legions. Fulvia kind of raises a war against him. I mean, she's a very, very formidable woman. And clearly, Antony likes very strong, powerful women. To use your terminology, Tom, she really is a baggage.
因此，他们在意大利山麓的布林迪西举行了一场会议、一场峰会。雷必达出席了会议。还有大庞培的儿子，他一直在西西里经营着一个敲诈勒索、海盗式的王国。他们构建了一个本应是某种城邦和解协议的框架。但实际上，安东尼和屋大维在做的事情是瓜分世界。从这一点来看——我的意思是，小庞培在此之后很快就被消灭了。雷必达被晾在一边。他成了大祭司长，也就是最高神职人员，但他成了一个无名小卒。屋大维回到了罗马。在忍受了所有敌意和不受欢迎的待遇、平息了军团的安置问题之后，他现在开始与
She really is a baggage. Well, yeah, she's a very, very strong, potent, formidable woman. But she drops dead, doesn't she? She does, yeah. And Anthony's reaction to that is not, oh, great, I can marry Cleopatra. It's actually to form a marriage alliance with his fellow triumvir and his partner and rival, Octavian. He marries Octavia. He does. So they have a conference, a summit at he marries Octavia. He does.
罗马人民建立联系。他开始讨好他们，给他们想要的，为他们提供和平的保证。安东尼回到了东方。但正如你所说，他们同盟的象征以及彼此和平共处的意愿，体现在安东尼娶了屋大维的妹妹屋大维娅。但这进展得相当顺利，不是吗？她是个可爱的人。是的，因为屋大维娅是一位非常、非常令人印象深刻的女性。是的。她研读哲学。她很聪明。
So they have a conference, a summit at Brandisium on the hill of Italy, at which Lepidus is there. And the son of Pompey the Great, who's been kind of running a rackety, piratical kind of kingdom based in Sicily. And they construct what's supposed to be a kind of concordat. But effectively, what Antony and Octavian are doing is dividing the world between them. And from this point on, I mean, Sextus Pompey gets eliminated very rapidly after this. Lepidus gets parked. He becomes Pontifex Maximus, so the chief priest, but he becomes a nobody. And Octavian goes back to Rome. And after all the hostility and the unpopularity that he's had to endure, kind of settling the legions, he is now starting to bond with the
她很美丽。是的，她很善良。心地善良，对安东尼极其忠诚。而且她自始至终对安东尼都忠心耿耿。在最初的这三四年里，他并没有刻意地为克莉奥帕特拉苦苦相思。我的意思是，克莉奥帕特拉早就被遗忘了。不，绝对没有。所以他们当时在雅典。
Roman people. He's starting to tickle their tummies, give them what they want, provide them with the assurance of peace. Antony goes back to the East. But as you say, the symbol of their alliance and of their willingness to live with each other is that Antony marries Octavian's sister, Octavia. But that goes quite well, doesn't it? She's a lovely person. Yeah, because Octavia is a very, very impressive woman. Yeah. She's studied philosophy. She's intelligent.
他打扮成狄奥尼索斯。诸如此类的事情。他对人和善。扮演着哲学家的角色，诸如此类。是的。所以在某种程度上，此时此刻——公元前40、39、38年——世界处于一种平衡状态。屋大维拥有西方，克莉奥帕特拉在埃及过着她自己的日子，组织粮食运输、研究尼罗河并建造神庙。
She's beautiful. Yeah, she's kind. Kind and incredibly loyal to Antony. And she's loyal to Antony right the way through. For those first three or four years, he's not ostentatiously pining for Cleopatra. I mean, Cleopatra's forgotten. No, absolutely not. So they're there in Athens.
安东尼和屋大维娅在东方。我想，汤姆，你觉得那种局势本质上是不稳定的吗？还是说你认为那种稳定性本可以持续下去？我认为它本质上就是不稳定的。你认为是由于屋大维和安东尼之间的竞争导致的吗？因为我认为屋大维太有野心、太精明了，无法容忍自己不能统治全世界的想法。我想安东尼可能也是。
He dresses up as Dionysus. All that kind of stuff. He's being nice to people. Plays at being a philosopher, all that kind of thing. Yeah. So in a way, at this point, 40, 39, 38 BC, the world is in balance. Octavian has the West, Cleopatra is in Egypt and just doing her thing and organizing grain shipments and studying the Nile and building temples.
我的意思是，他们两个都是相当可怕的人。屋大维——我们还没怎么谈论过他，因为他显然将成为奥古斯特（奥古斯都），可以说整个人类历史上最核心的人物之一。你知道的，就……你和我前几天在一次公共活动中被问及
Antony is in the East with Octavia. And I suppose, do you think that situation, Tom, was inherently unstable? Or do you think that stability could have persisted? I think it's inherently unstable. Because of the rivalry between Octavian and Antony, do you think? Because I think Octavian was too ambitious and too shrewd to tolerate the idea of not ruling the whole world. I think Antony might have been.
关于政治领导力的问题时，他绝对是巅峰，是政治领导力的典范。但是屋大维，关于他最不可思议的事情——我说过他可以由汤姆·赫兰德、由彼得·帕克来扮演——是他很年轻，未经历练，名不见经传。我的意思是，到这个时候，他已经接受了半生不熟的政治教育。当然，他通过家族与尤利乌斯·凯撒有联系，但他并不是个伟大的统帅。他不是。你知道的，他继承了凯撒的名字和凯撒的钱。
I mean, they're both pretty terrifying men. Octavian, who we haven't really talked about because he obviously is going to go on to become Augustus, arguably one of the central characters in all human history. You know, right up there in terms of, you and I were asked the other day
是的。而且他才18岁。你知道的，他直接去了罗马，利用这一切把所有人都玩弄于股掌之间。你知道的，他背叛了西塞罗。有一会儿他在与安东尼战斗，然后他又与安东尼结盟。他是一个具有绝对超越性天才的政治家。到了30年代初，他已经有资格让他的财富和地位真正发挥作用，真正产生影响力，成为罗马事实上的主人。汤姆，你觉得呢？所以在意大利有这样一个家伙，安东尼以前无疑看不起他，认为他不过是个乳臭未干的毛头小子，在关键的菲利普比战役中因为生病而无法参战；而现在，这个家伙正在将自己蜕变成一个极其高明的政治家。安东尼是否觉得他必须做出一些壮观的举动来与之竞争？这就是原因吗？还是你觉得他一直都想入侵帕提亚——这正是那个将改变他们所有人命运的重大致命举动？
at a public event when we, about political leadership and he is the absolute acme, the paradigmatic example of political leadership. But Octavian, and the extraordinary thing about him, I mean, I said he could be played by Tom Holland, by Peter Parker, is that he is young, he is untried, he's obscure. I mean, by this point, he's had a political education and a half. Sure, he was connected by families of Julius Caesar, but he's not a great commander. He's not. You know, he inherits Caesar's name and Caesar's money.
我认为这是一种典型的情况：老牌政客开始感到自己受到了年轻后起之秀的威胁。我认为这绝对是其中的一部分。但我认为这也关乎继承凯撒的衣钵。屋大维显然已经做到了这一点，因为他字面意义上——你知道的，人们不叫他屋大维，是的，他叫凯撒，他就是尤利乌斯·凯撒，这就是他的名字。而安东尼想要接管凯撒在遇刺前未能完成的角色——征服帕提亚。这具有一种神话般的共鸣，再次与他正在对克莉奥帕特拉做的一切相呼应，因为你知道亚历山大征服了波斯，有一种说法是狄奥尼索斯率领大军从东方而来，所以这其中有着某种呼应，你知道的，这就像海格力斯完成的伟大壮举一样。所以他想这样做的原因有很多。正如你所暗示的，这确实是安东尼与屋大维关系的一个重大转折点，而且并非巧合的是，这也是他与克莉奥帕特拉关系的一个转折点。所以也许我们可以在中场休息后再谈这个。我们现在处于公元前37年。安东尼想要入侵帕提亚。他即将与克莉奥帕特拉重聚。我们中场休息后见。
Yeah. And he's 18. You know, he goes straight to Rome and he uses this and he plays everybody off. You know, he double crosses Cicero. At one point he's fighting Antony, then he makes an alliance with anthony he is a politician of absolute transcendent genius by the the kind of the early 30s he is in a position to make his his wealth and his status as the effective master of rome really really tell really count and do you think tom so you've got this guy in Italy who has Anthony previously undoubtedly looked down on as a sort of beardless boy who had been too ill to fight at the crucial Battle of Philippi and who is transforming himself into this incredibly adept politician. he feels he has to do something spectacular to compete and that's what or do you think he always wanted to invade Parthia which is this great fatal move that will change all of their lives
不要走开。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的残余》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家特辑以及优先购买现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。所以，马克·安东尼脑子里盘算着入侵帕提亚。
I think that it's the kind of the classic situation where you have the elder statesman who starts to feel threatened by the kind of the young upstart I think that's absolutely part of it but I think it's also it's about claiming the mantle of caesar uh octavian has obviously done that because he is literally you know he's he's not known as octavian yeah he's called caesar he is julius caesar that's his name and anthony wants to to take over the role that caesar was going to do before his assassination and conquer parthia um and that has a kind of mythic resonance that again plays with all this stuff that he's doing with Cleopatra because you know that Alexander conquered Persia there's the sense that Dionysus came from the east at the head of a great army so there's kind of echoes there uh you know it's a
这基本上就是波斯帝国，对吧，汤姆？它是被亚历山大推翻的波斯帝国的继承国。所以帕提亚人来自伊朗北部。他们是一种贵族，武士贵族。他们自认为是超级大国，对吧？他们的实力不如罗马，但又强悍到无法轻易被吞噬。他们的军事力量是罗马不擅长应对的那种类型。所以罗马的优势显然是它的步兵，重步兵，军团，训练有素，是世界上最高效的步兵。而帕提亚的
great labor like Hercules did so there's all kinds of of reasons for why he wants to do this you know as you as you intimate it's really the kind of the great turning point in the relationship of Antony with Octavian, but also, and not coincidentally, with Cleopatra. So perhaps we should come to that after the break. We're in 37 BC. Antony wants to invade Parthia. He's about to be reunited with Cleopatra. And we will see you after the break.
优势则是机动性极高的骑射手。这已经导致了一次罗马军队在卡莱战役中的惨败，当时凯撒和庞培昔日的同僚克拉苏在那里栽了跟头。所以这也是安东尼想要做的事情的一部分。他想为克拉苏复仇。但他需要钱。而提供资金的人正是他的旧情人。他的昔日恋人，克莉奥帕特拉。克莉奥帕特拉。所以克莉奥帕特拉这段时间……我的意思是，我们之所以通过罗马人的视角讲述这么多内容，是因为正如我们在前几集里所说的那样，资料就是这样的。叙事史料都是罗马的视角。所以当罗马人遇到她时，她就会出现。而当她退居幕后时，我们其实就不得而知了。所以据我们所知，她一直在亚历山大过得很开心，
Don't go away. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So, Mark Antony has it in mind to invade Parthia.
抚养着她的孩子们。而且我认为她一直在尼罗河上下视察。所以，是的，她一直在奉献神庙，在各地被雕刻成法老的形象。没错，埃及丹德拉有一座神庙，上面展示了她与恺撒里昂——是的，托勒密·凯撒在一起的形象。所以她正以极大的热情扮演着法老的角色，并且取得了巨大的成功。他们非常非常成功。她并没有被赶下台，也没有针对她的重大骚乱和叛乱。我的意思是，我认为她被爱戴着。是的。她深受埃及人民的爱戴。
This is the Persian Empire, basically, isn't it, Tom? It's the inherited state to the Persian Empire that had been overthrown by Alexander. So the Parthians come from the north of Iran. They're a kind of aristocracy, warrior aristocracy. They are the superpower in their own minds anyway, aren't they? They are a lesser power than Rome, but they are too formidable to be readily digestible. Their military is of a kind that Rome is not suited to fighting. So Rome's strength is obviously its infantry, its heavy infantry, the legions, highly trained, the most efficient infantry in the world. But the Parthian
所以这一切都进行得极其顺利。但随后，在看似辉煌凯旋、实则充满苦涩讽刺的时刻，她被安东尼传召到安提阿——这是一个拥有宏伟背景、美丽无比的城市。塞琉古帝国的伟大首都。也就是托勒密王朝昔日灭亡的竞争对手。她抵达了，正是在这个时候，安东尼开始做出——汤姆，我认为——
strength is very mobile horse archers. And this has already led to a crushing defeat for a Roman army at the Battle of Cari, where Caesar and Pompey's erstwhile colleague Crassus had come a cropper. And so that's also a part of what Antony wants to do. He wants revenge for Crassus. But he needs money. And the person to get it from is his ex-lover. His old flame, Cleopatra. Cleopatra. So Cleopatra, all this time... I mean, the reason we're telling so much of it through the Roman lens is because that's the sources, as we've said in previous episodes. The narrative sources are Roman. So she appears when the Romans meet her. And then when she's off stage, we don't really know. So as far as we know, she has been in Alexandria quite happily,
一些糟糕的决策，战略上的糟糕决策。首先，她带着她为他生下的双胞胎——亚历山大·赫利俄斯和克莉奥帕特拉·塞勒涅——一同出场了，当时他们大约三岁吧。他承认他们是自己的骨肉，不是吗？他确实承认了。另外发生的一件事是，屋大维娅也为他生了个孩子，但是个女孩，而克莉奥帕特拉给他生了个男孩。所以他这样做，大概是因为他极度渴望克莉奥帕特拉的资金，你觉得呢？是的，绝对是这样。而且屋大维的敌意也变得越来越明朗了，没错。但随后——
bringing up her children. And I think up and down the nile so yeah she is dedicating temples she's being sculpted as a pharaoh on various that's right there's a temple egypt a dendera that shows her with caesarian yeah ptolemy caesar so she is playing the role of pharaoh with great gusto and doing it very successfully they're very very successful she's not being kicked out there aren't riots and rebellions of any significance against her. I mean, she's loved, I think. Yeah. She's loved by the Egyptians.
但接着他做的另一件事——克莉奥帕特拉的职业生涯中有两次被称为“捐赠”的事件，这是第一次，
So that's all going splendidly. But then what appears to be a triumphant moment, but actually turns out to be sort of bitterly ironic, she is summoned by Antony to Antioch in this magnificent setting, beautiful city. The great capital of the Seleucid Empire. So the extinct rival of the Ptolemies she arrives and it's at this point that Antony starts to make Tom I would argue
即安提阿捐赠，安东尼基本上将大片领土授予了她。也就是现在的黎巴嫩、加沙、奇里乞亚、利比亚的昔兰尼、杰里科周边的土地，
some poor decisions strategically poor decisions so first of all she pitches up with the twins that she had had his twins Alexander Helios and Cleopatra Selene who are about three I think he acknowledges them doesn't he as his own he does and something else that has happened is that octavia has also given her a child but it's a girl so cleopatra has given him a boy so he does this presumably because he's desperate for cleopatra's money do you think yeah definitely and also octavian is becoming more overt in his hostility as well yeah but then But then the other thing he does, so there are two moments called donations in Cleopatra's career, and this is the first,
那里盛产备受珍视的香脂树。是的，是从希罗德手里拿过来的。是的，希罗德不是很高兴……希罗德，当然是一个……我的意思是，我们可能不会花太多时间讨论希罗德，但希罗德在这其中只是个小角色，不是吗？克莉奥帕特拉和希罗德互相仇恨。
the donations of Antioch, where Antony basically awards her a lot of territory. So what's now Lebanon, Gaza, Silesia, Cyrene in Libya, the lands around Jericho,
此时，安东尼把许多曾属于托勒密帝国的领土交给了她。转瞬间，她的统治范围变得大得多。这到底是怎么回事？这些领土拥有木材资源。尤其是黎巴嫩，以木材闻名。木材能让你建造一支舰队。所以安东尼在未雨绸缪，因为在意大利发生的事情是，屋大维和他的得力助手、好朋友玛库斯·阿格里帕在那不勒斯湾建造了一个庞大的海军基地，表面上他们用这个基地击败了年轻的庞培。他们确实做到了这一点。
which are very rich in balsam trees, which are prized. Yeah, it takes us from Herod. Yeah, Herod's not very... Herod, of course, is a... I mean, we won't sort of probably spend too much time on Herod, but Herod is a sort of a minor player in all this, isn't he? Cleopatra and Herod hate each other.
但很显然，如果世界上这两大领袖之间将要爆发战争，海上力量将至关重要。而安东尼此时还没有舰队。所以基本上，我认为他正在把建造舰队的任务外包给克莉奥帕特拉，这就是正在发生的事情。我认为这是最主要的动机。所以即使在这个阶段，他也在为未来争夺世界命运的决战做准备。是的，我也这么认为。
At this point, Antony is giving her a lot of territory that used to belong to the Ptolemaic Empire. Suddenly, she's ruling much bigger. What's going on here? These are territories that have timber. So particularly Lebanon, famously. And timber enables you to build a fleet so anthony is looking ahead because what's happening in italy is that octavian and his uh right hand man uh best friend marcus gripper have built a massive naval base in the bay of naples which ostensibly they've used to defeat the young Pompey. And they have done that.
而且他需要克莉奥帕特拉作为他的合伙人。是的。尽管他已经结婚了。我认为屋大维的敌意、屋大维娅只给他生了个女儿而不是儿子、克莉奥帕特拉给他生了个儿子，以及克莉奥帕特拉非常非常富有并带来了这种君主制统治的潜力，这一切说服了他：“我要向那个方向倾斜。”当然，在这个时候，如果你是克莉奥帕特拉，这看起来太棒了。所以她在埃及采用了一种新的历法。
But obviously, if there's going to be a war between the two great leaders of the world, sea power is going to be crucial. And Antony at this point doesn't have a fleet. So essentially, he's subcontracting the task of building a fleet to Cleopatra, I think is what's going on. I think that's the prime. So even at this stage, he's looking ahead to a showdown for the future of the world. Yeah, I think so.
她说：“这是元年，而不是我统治的第16年，”以此来标榜这是一个崭新的帝国，或者说是一个复兴的帝国。他们拥有非常复杂的头衔，不是吗？所以以前她是克莉奥帕特拉，爱父女神；而现在她是爱父爱国女神，以此来巩固她是国家的母亲、重建了帝国等等这一事实。如果你是克莉奥帕特拉，此时此刻——我们现在是公元前37年——看起来你牌打得相当不错，对吧？我的意思是，安东尼……没有任何理由怀疑。我觉得你的牌打得简直惊艳绝伦。
And he needs Cleopatra as his partner. Yeah. Despite the fact he's married already. I think Octavian's hostility, the fact that Octavia has only given him a girl rather than a boy, and Cleopatra has given him a son, and the fact that, you know, Cleopatra's just very, very rich, and she brings all this kind of potential for a kind of monarchical type rule, I think it persuades him, I'm going to tilt that way. And of course, at this point, if you're Cleopatra, this looks great. So she adopts a new calendar in
是的。我的意思是，你是那个看起来将要统治世界的男人的合伙人。于是安东尼在公元前36年春天出发前往帕提亚，他将穿过大致相当于现在的亚美尼亚。他得和它达成协议——好吧，那时是亚美尼亚。是的。好吧，亚美尼亚经常变动。是的。他得和亚美尼亚国王阿塔瓦斯德达成协议。克莉奥帕特拉陪他一直走到幼发拉底河，然后折返回去，以便她能够视察
Egypt. She says, this is year one, not year 16 in my reign, to sort of mark the fact that it's a new empire, as it were, or a revived empire. And they have these very complicated titles, don't they? So previously been Cleopatra, the father-loving goddess, and now she's the father-loving, homeland-loving goddess to sort of cement the fact that she is the mother of the country who has rebuilt the empire and all this stuff. And if you're Cleopatra, it looks at this point, what are we, 37 BC, as if you've played your cards pretty well, no? I mean, Antony, there's no reason to doubt. I think you've played your cards dazzlingly well.
她的新领地，也就是黎巴嫩那些地方。安东尼则去进攻米底亚的阿特罗帕特尼省——也就是，我想大致是现在的伊朗西北部，汤姆，大概是这样吧——那是帕提亚人的发源地。与此同时，克莉奥帕特拉回到了亚历山大。她生了第四个孩子，她和安东尼显然又重修旧好了。是的，她生了一个名叫托勒密·费拉德尔菲斯的男孩，我觉得这个名字太耐人寻味了，因为他是托勒密帝国鼎盛时期第二位叫托勒密·费拉德尔菲斯的君主，我觉得这个名字太耐人寻味了，因为它是托勒密帝国鼎盛时期的第二个托勒密——是的，他叫托勒密·费拉德尔菲斯，第一个叫亚历山大，所以她的野心简直昭然若揭。但她显然在等待来自帕提亚的消息，盼着一切顺利、安东尼
Yeah. I mean, you're the partner and a guy who looks like he's going to take over the world. So off Antony goes in the spring of 36 to Parthia, and he's going to go through kind of vaguely what's now Armenia. He's got a deal with it. Well, it was Armenia then. Yeah. Well, Armenia sort of shifts. Yeah. go through kind of vaguely what's now armenia he's got a deal with armenia then yeah well armenia sort of shift yeah yeah um he's got a deal with the armenian king who's art of as these cleopatra goes with him as far as the euphrates and then turns back to so that she can inspect
凯旋而归。但事情并没有完全按计划发展，对吧？基本上，安东尼诸事不顺。他灰头土脸地回来了，而克莉奥帕特拉基本上不得不去拯救他。嗯，他出现在贝鲁特附近。所以她收到消息，去贝鲁特见他，并顺便带上了衣服和补给。因为贝鲁特是一个罗马殖民地，所以那里是你在近东能找到的极具罗马特色地方。
her new kingdoms sort of lebanon stuff and off anthony goes to attack the province of media at atropatine which is um sort of i guess northwestern iran tom that's probably about right which is where the party has come from now in the meantime cleopatra goes back to alexandria she has a fourth child so and she and anthony clearly got it on again yeah um she has a child called ptolemy philadelphus and i think that's so suggestive the name because it's the second ptolemy at the peak of called Ptolemy Philadelphus and I think that's so suggestive the name because it's the second Ptolemy at the peak of the Ptolemaic empire yeah it's called Ptolemy Philadelphus the first one is Alexander so it couldn't be clearer what her ambitions are but and she's obviously waiting for news from from Parthia that all has gone well and Anthony
据说她抵达时，他的手下一个个衣衫褴褛、痛苦不堪。安东尼则盯着自己的地面发呆哭泣，一切都糟透了。他们被困在了群山之中，到达了一座名叫弗拉什帕的城堡，但没能攻克它，于是他们决定原路返回——有点像拿破仑兵败莫斯科或者别的什么——他们在山里遭遇了严寒。安东尼甚至有一刻精神崩溃，动了自杀的念头。突然之间，在这一瞬间，所有的不可战胜的神话光环……
has carried all before him but it doesn't quite work out does, does it? Basically, it all goes wrong for Antony. He comes back with the tail between his legs, and Cleopatra essentially has to come and kind of rescue him. Well, he turns up near Beirut. So she gets a message to come and see him in Beirut and bring basically clothes, supplies. Because Beirut is a Roman colony, so it's as Roman a place as you'll get in the Near East.
一直所向披靡，但事情进展得并不太顺利，对吧？基本上，安东尼的一切都搞砸了。他灰溜溜地回来了，而克娄巴特拉基本上不得不去救他。嗯，他在贝鲁特附近出现了。于是她派人传信让他去贝鲁特见她，并带上衣服和补给。因为贝鲁特是罗马殖民地，所以那里是近东最具罗马特色地方。
And supposedly she arrives and basically his men are bedraggled miserable anthony's kind of staring at his feet and crying and it's all gone horribly wrong they've got stuck in the mountains they get to a citadel called fraspa and they don't manage to take it and then they decide to go back again sort of napoleon in moscow or something and they freeze in the mountains. Anthony, at one point, has a breakdown and thinks he wants to kill himself. And suddenly, in this one moment, all the aura of invincibility
据说她到达时，安东尼的手下衣衫褴褛、痛苦不堪，安东尼则盯着自己的脚发呆并哭泣，一切都糟透了。他们被困在山里，到达了一个叫法斯帕的城堡却没能攻下，然后他们决定打道回府，有点像拿破仑兵败莫斯科那样，在山里冻得瑟瑟发抖。安东尼一度精神崩溃，甚至想自杀。突然之间，在这个时刻，所有战无不胜的光环
and kind of inevitable triumph just has completely disappeared from him. And I would say, I don't know if you think of this, I would say Mark Antony is never really the same man again after the failure of the Parthian expedition. Well, as you say, the aura of a kind of military prowess has received a knock, but I think he actually recovers pretty well. Essentially what he decides at this point is he's going to go all in with Cleopatra. You know, he is going to play the Hellenistic card. He's going to draw on the incredible resources that the Greek kingdoms in the Near East have always had, and of which Cleopatra
那种无法阻挡、势如破竹的胜利感在他身上完全消失了。我认为，我不知道你是否也这么想，马克·安东尼在帕提亚远征失败后，就再也不是以前那个男人了。正如你所说，那种军事才能的光环受到了打击，但我认为他其实恢复得相当不错。他在此时的基本决定是，他将全力押注于克利奥帕特拉。你知道，他要打希腊化这张牌。他要利用近东希腊王国一直以来拥有的惊人资源，而克利奥帕特拉正是这些资源的活生生的化身。
is the living embodiment. Of course, the relationship is now a much more equal one. He is a diminished figure. Cleopatra, her status has been raised. And it's from this point on, I think, that Cleopatra can credibly dream of establishing a dominion that would be a kind of Hellenistic Roman co-dominion that would bring her to a pinnacle of power and fame and glory, greater probably than she had dared to dream of. So Antony, he's failed to take to take path here but he does have a kind of consolation expedition doesn't he a couple of years later armenia has armenia yeah he captures the bloke art of astes who'd previously been his ally who he blames for the failure of his expedition he comes back to alexandria and i think this whatever the spring of 34 and then there's
当然，这段关系现在变得更加平等了。他是一个光芒减弱的人物，而克利奥帕特拉的地位则得到了提升。我认为，也正是从这一刻起，克利奥帕特拉可以满怀信心地梦想建立一个统治疆域，这将是一种希腊化与罗马化的共同统治，把她推向权力和声誉的巅峰，这很可能是她以前不敢梦想的高度。所以安东尼虽然未能攻占帕提亚，但几年后他确实进行了一次某种程度的安慰性远征，不是吗？亚美尼亚有亚美尼亚，对吧？他俘虏了阿尔塔瓦兹德，此人以前是他的盟友，他将远征失败归咎于此人。他回到亚历山大港，我想大约是在公元前34年的春天，接着发生了
these two extraordinary events so one is he holds a triumph in Alexandria. So the Romans call it a triumph because, you know, this is a standard ritual within the streets of Rome and you can only hold a triumph in Rome. Yeah. But the Ptolemies have had this tradition of military parades in Egypt as well. Because the Romans take against this, don't they? They're shocked. Octavian does. Because when Antony's come back from parthia octavia also has offered to come and to bring troops you know because this is meant to be the agreement yes of course and anthony says to her no don't come and this is an open insult this is the one of the first points where roman historians say he was bewitched by cleopatra she had a hissy fit and broke down in tears and basically browbeat him into doing this.
两件极其不寻常的事件：一是他举行了一场亚历山大港的凯旋式。罗马人称之为凯旋式，因为这是罗马街头的一个标准仪式，而且你只能在罗马举行凯旋式。是的。但托勒密王朝在埃及也有这种军事阅兵的传统。因为罗马人对此感到不满，不是吗？他们震惊了。屋大维就是如此。因为当安东尼从帕提亚回来时，屋大维娅也曾提出要来并带来军队，你知道的，因为这本该是协议的一部分。是的，当然，而安东尼对她说：“别来。”这是一个公开的侮辱，这是罗马历史学家们首次指出他被克利奥帕特拉迷住的关键点之一，她当时大发脾气、泪流满面，基本上是逼迫他这样做的。
We'll come to how this is all being spun in Rome perhaps later on. But essentially in Rome, Octavian spin doctors are saying he has become emasculated because this is what happens to weak Romans in the East. The East is wealthy. It's effeminate. It's sapping. Even the greatest heroes succumb. And Antony has been comparing himself to Heracles. But one of the notorious episodes in Heracles' life is when he becomes a slave of a queen called Omphale. And Omphale puts on Heracles' lion skin, the armor that he's been always traditionally wears, and makes Heracles put on her dress and spin at the
我们或许以后会谈到这一切在罗马是如何被大肆炒作的。但本质上，在罗马，屋大维的舆论操纵者们宣称他被阉割了，因为这就是东方的罗马弱者所遭遇的下场。东方是富裕的、柔弱的、消磨意志的。即使最伟大的英雄也会屈服。安东尼一直将自己比作赫拉克勒斯。但赫拉克勒斯生平中臭名昭著的一幕，就是他成为了一个名叫翁法勒的女王的奴隶。翁法勒穿上了赫拉克勒斯的狮皮衣——也就是他传统上总是穿戴的盔甲，并让赫拉克勒斯穿上她的长裙，在织布机旁纺纱。
loom. People start to say, this is what's happened to Antony. He is, you know, Cleopatra is on Fale. Antony is an effeminized Heracles. And essentially he's become a traitor to Rome. And so this spin that the parades that have been held in Alexandria are a deliberate parody of the triumphs in Rome and therefore Antony's disrespecting Rome and Roman tradition. You know, it's kind of, it's brilliant. As you say, there is a second episode, which is even, provides even more grist to Octavian's propaganda mill.
人们开始说，这就是安东尼的下场。他，你知道的，克利奥帕特拉就是翁法勒，安东尼就是一个被女性化的赫拉克勒斯。本质上，他成了罗马的叛徒。因此这种舆论渲染认为，在亚历山大港举行的游行是对罗马凯旋式的蓄意嘲讽，因此安东尼是对罗马和罗马传统的极度不敬。你知道，这真是……太高明了。正如你所说，还有第二个事件，它为屋大维的宣传机器提供了更多的炮弹。
So this, again, is a brilliant example of how, you know, from Cleopatra's point of view, this is her apotheosis, the second episode. But of course, for Octavian, it is an absolute gift. And this is, thisotheosis the second episode but of course for octavian it is an absolute gift and this is this happens at the gymnasium the area where people would stroll and do sports and all this kind of thing you know because it's a greek city alexandria and it's called the donations of alexandria isn't it and it's this incredible if you read their descriptions this incredible spectacle where people just all pile in so it's a great sort of public festivity and anthony leads on he comes on stage with
所以，这同样是一个极好的例子，说明从克利奥帕特拉的角度来看，第二个事件是她的登峰造极之作。但当然，对于屋大维来说，这绝对是一份天赐的礼物。这发生在体育馆，也就是人们散步和进行体育运动以及做各种此类事情的地方，你知道的，因为亚历山大港是一个希腊城市，它被称为亚历山大奉献，不是吗？如果你读当时的描述，这是一场令人难以置信的壮观景象，人们蜂拥而至，这是一场盛大的公共庆典，安东尼带头，他与
cleopatra and their children and julius caesar's uh son caesarian and he basically introduces them all to the crowd according to the sources and says caesarian is the true heir of julius caesar alexander helios is the king of Armenia and Media. Even though he doesn't rule them. Exactly. Cleopatra Selene is the queen of Crete and Cyrene. And little Ptolemy Philadelphus, who's a toddler, is the king of Phoenicia, Syria, and Silesia.
克利奥帕特拉以及他们的孩子、还有尤利乌斯·恺撒的儿子恺撒里昂一起登上了舞台，根据史料记载，他基本上向大众介绍了他们所有人，并宣布恺撒里昂是尤利乌斯·恺撒真正的继承人，亚历山大·赫利俄斯是亚美尼亚和米底亚的国王。尽管他并不统治这些地方。没错。克利奥帕特拉·塞勒涅是克里特和昔兰尼的女王。而年幼的托勒密·费拉德尔夫斯还只是个蹒跚学步的孩子，他被封为腓尼基、叙利亚和奇里乞亚的国王。
And they're all dressed in kind of national dress of these places. I mean, Ptolemy Philadelphus has basically been given the path in empire, which Antony's just failed to conquer. So the whole thing is a kind of, on one level, castle in the sky, but on the other level, it's presenting Antony's rule as something that is, in a way, not founded exclusively on Roman predominance. So he's offering a kind of, to all the peoples of the East, a model of what a Roman-Egyptian kind of fusion might look like. Well, it's a sort of successor to Alexander's empire, isn't it? Kind of. It's Greek and it's Asian.
他们都穿着这些地方的民族服饰。我的意思是，托勒密·费拉德尔夫斯基本上被授予了安东尼刚刚未能征服的帕提亚帝国。所以整件事从某种层面来看就像是空中楼阁，但从另一个层面来看，它将安东尼的统治呈现为一种在某种程度上并非完全建立在罗马主导地位之上的形式。因此，他向东方所有人民提供了一种罗马与埃及融合的模式。嗯，这有点像是亚历山大帝国的继承者，不是吗？有点像。它既是希腊的，又是亚洲的。
It includes Persia. And yet his thing, so from Cleopatra's point of view, this really is the apogee, because she is being told that she and her children rule all the East, are the masters of the world and all this stuff, even though they don't actually control half of these lands. But how can Antony not see that from the point of view of Rome, this is the most colossal PR disaster to be giving away all this territory to kind of Eastern princelings? I mean, at this point, or do you think he's just desperate and he doesn't care? No, I don't. I mean, he's got all to play for. Essentially, the challenge that has faced Julius Caesar and all his heir, everyone who's followed after him, is how do you square a Republican system of government with a universal empire? This is this is the problem and this is a challenge that people in the east have been facing as well and that you know they're richer
它包括波斯。然而，从克利奥帕特拉的角度来看，这确实是巅峰，因为她被告知她和她的孩子统治着整个东方，是世界的统治者诸如此类，尽管他们实际上并未控制这些土地的一半。但是，安东尼怎么会看不出，从罗马的角度来看，把所有这些领土分给东方的王公贵族是一场巨大无比的公关灾难？我的意思是，在这个时候，还是你觉得他只是走投无路，已经不在乎了？不，我不这么认为。我的意思是，他还有很多筹码。本质上，尤利乌斯·恺撒以及他的所有继承人、所有跟随他的人所面临的挑战是，你如何将共和制的政府系统与一个普世帝国调和？这就是问题所在，这也是东方的人民一直在面临的挑战，你知道的，他们更富有，
they're kind of more antiquated there are traditions there that can be exploited caesar had recognized that anthony has recognized that anthony is clumsier and less kind of ideologically proficient than caesar had been caesar had up murdered, but the temptation had been such that he was willing to have a go. Basically, Antony is tempted by, you know, it's the same temptation. It's the idea of stepping beyond the kind of resentful kind of Republican traditions that you get in Rome, where everyone is always jealous of each other. It provides the kind of the dazzling prospect that you might be able to establish a monarchical tradition, a dynasty, draw on all this kind of the dazzling prospect that you might be able to establish a monarchical tradition, a dynasty, draw on all this kind of great inheritance of Middle Eastern monarchy,
他们更加古老，那里有可以被利用的传统。恺撒已经意识到了这一点，安东尼也意识到了这一点，只是安东尼比恺撒更笨拙，在意识形态上也不如恺撒那么娴熟。恺撒曾被谋杀，但这种诱惑是如此巨大，以至于他愿意去尝试。基本上，安东尼受到了诱惑，你知道的，这是同样的诱惑。这就是超越罗马那种充满怨恨的共和传统的想法，在那种传统中，每个人都对彼此嫉妒。它提供了一种耀眼的前景，即你或许能够建立一种君主制传统、一个王朝，并汲取所有中东君主制的伟大遗产，
Near Eastern monarchy, Greek monarchy, while at the same time remaining Roman. And in the long run, this is basically where Rome ends up, you know, by the fourth century, fifth century, Constantinople would be a city that in a way is pretty comprehensible to Antony. And his only problem is that he's 400 years too early. Yes, to square this kind of global rule with Roman traditions is a challenging, challenging thing. The approach that you're going to take is basically, by this point, based on where the two challenges are situated. So Antony is situated in Alexandria. So obviously, if those traditions are to hand, those are the ones that he's got to play with.
近东君主制、希腊君主制，同时又保持罗马人的身份。长远来看，这基本上就是罗马最终的归宿，你知道的，到了四世纪、五世纪，君士坦丁堡将会成为一个在某种程度上让安东尼能够理解的城市。他唯一的错误在于他早生了400年。是的，要将这种全球统治与罗马传统调和是一件极具挑战性的事情。你将采取的方法基本上取决于当时两个挑战所处的位置。因此，安东尼身处亚历山大港。所以很明显，如果那些传统触手可及，那就是他必须利用的传统。
You know, he doesn't have any choice. Octavian is back in Rome. He can play the Roman card. We should stop our third episode here. And when we look at the fourth episode, we should come back and we should look at what Octavian is saying about Antony and Cleopatra, because this is really crucial to how posterity has come to see them and their romance and everything. Agreed. Could I take us out with a poem by the great Alexandrian poet, Constantine Cavafy? He briefly stayed in Liverpool as a child. So he's a kind of scouse Alexandrian. He was obsessed with this
你知道，他别无选择。屋大维回到了罗马，他可以打罗马牌。我们第三集就在这里结束吧。当我们看第四集时，我们应该回来看看屋大维对安东尼和克利奥帕特拉的评价，因为这对于后人如何看待他们以及他们的浪漫史等一切至关重要。同意。我能用伟大的亚历山大诗人康斯坦丁·卡瓦菲的一首诗来结束这一集吗？他童年时曾在利物浦短暂停留。所以他有点像利物浦的亚历山大港人。他痴迷于这段历史时期，即亚历山大的希腊化时期。他写了一首关于亚历山大奉献的绝妙诗篇，名叫《亚历山大诸王》：
period of history, with the Hellenistic period of Alexandria. And he wrote a fabulous poem about the donations of Alexandria called The Alexandrian Kings. The Alexandrians flocked to view the children of Cleopatra, Kazarian and his little brothers, Alexander and Ptolemy, who for the first time had been brought out to the gymnasium to be proclaimed kings there, amidst the gleaming company of soldiers on parade. Alexander, him they named king of Armenia, Media and the Parthians. Ptolemy, him they named king of Cilicia, Syria and Phoenicia. Caesarian was standing furthest forward, dressed in rose-toned
亚历山大港人蜂拥而至，去观看克利奥帕特拉的孩子们：恺撒里昂和他的小弟弟们亚历山大和托勒密，他们生平第一次被带到体育馆，在那里的阅兵队列闪闪发光的士兵陪伴下，被宣告为国王。亚历山大，他被命名为亚美尼亚、米底亚和帕提亚的国王。托勒密，他被命名为奇里乞亚、叙利亚和腓尼基的国王。恺撒里昂站在最前面，身穿玫瑰色的丝绸长袍，胸前缀满风信子，腰带上镶嵌着成对的蓝宝石和紫水晶，鞋带由缀着玫瑰红珍珠的白丝带系紧，他被命名为比弟弟们更高贵的人，他被命名为万王之王。
silk, on his breast a clutch of hyacinths, his belt paired lines of sapphires and amethysts, his shoes laced by white ribbons pinned with rose-blush pearls, him they named higher than the younger ones, him they named King of Kings. The Alexandrians certainly understood that these were words and histrionics. But the day was warm and poetic, the sky a clear wide blue, the Alexandrian gymnasium a triumphant artistic feat. The courtier's luxury at its crest, Caesarian all grace and beauty, the son of Cleopatra, blood of the Larchids. And the Alexandrians raced to the festive name day and worked themselves into raptures and called out cheers in Greek, in Egyptian, and some in Hebrew, enchanted by the lovely spectacle.
亚历山大港人当然明白这些只是言辞和做作。但那天天气温暖而富有诗意，天空晴朗辽阔，亚历山大港的体育馆是一项凯旋的艺术杰作。朝臣的奢华达到了顶峰，恺撒里昂集优雅与美貌于一身，他是克利奥帕特拉的儿子，拉戛德王朝的血脉。亚历山大港人争先恐后地涌向这庆典的命名日，情绪激昂，狂喜不已，用希腊语、埃及语欢呼，有些人还用希伯来语欢呼，被这迷人的景象深深陶醉。
Even though they very clearly knew the value of these things, what inane words made up these titled kings. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news
尽管他们非常清楚这些东西的价值，明白这些冠冕堂皇的国王头衔不过是空洞的词藻。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家剧集、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻的阵地，
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club
包括各类评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，
if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想要无广告收听、独家剧集以及提前获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。